i guess i'm asking
what do you expect
what would your goals be when you leave
what would you like to know when you
leave
i'm not quite sure about this that's
okay
have a think we can come back i think
the
maybe just use the
we
we have to use the word uh also use the
link website to learn it
and have and have a real conversation
with native speakers uh
first i wanna learn english of course
and
i wanna
learn english more
to be more fluently
and after that
um
if anyone needs some help for english
then i want to help from
them because i i never
go abroad to study english and
um i want to help especially for those
who
the same people as i am
so english-wise it would be
that uh
now i i'm
capable of
living my life here and and
working as a waiter or body style or
something in hospitality
but i
as i mentioned in my email like maybe my
video as well that i really want to
to reach a bit higher level
come on
as we discussed you know chinese
people's chinese is softer it doesn't
have strong
consonants that end words and stuff
so there's and there's this l r issue so
see if you can say relinquish
that's pretty good
yeah relinquish all right
save virtually
that's not bad that's good that's good
say there
you see that's your biggest issue right
now the one you have to focus on it's
there
that's interesting how do you get your
lair
okay what do you think when pigs fly
it's like
i will win the lottery
next week and then your friend can say
oh yeah you will when the pigs fly
put your money where your mouth is
put your money where your mouth is
i think it's kind of
um
uh
eat something really delicious
hey it's thomas speaking how are you
doing today
good thank you very much uh
i'm just wondering uh we are
uh organizing an uh event
on uh on the fourth of
august on a thursday
and um i'm just wondering if you are
busy on on thursday nights
after i practice listening
i want to use it i want to use my words
i want to use phrases so i want to speak
in english so i
joined the telephone english
when i was in university there's a
program about telephone english with
native speakers professors so i joined
that program i think i don't have so
much time here and
i have to
take these
challenges seriously so
i just forced myself to stay there and
do something it was an interesting
experiment because a lot of people come
to vancouver
to learn english and they go to school
and they sit in class
and here the experiment was that the
studying they would do on their own
within link and then they would just be
interacting in a meaningful way with
with speakers of the language and i've
always felt that this is better if i
could spend a bunch of time working with
a language on link say and then go
somewhere and be surrounded by people
and be able to interact with them as far
superior to going to a school especially
since it was in context and that was
part of our
methodology i guess our approach when we
created it we wanted
context that they were interested in in
this case it was the startup environment
and they wanted to learn more about the
various things that we do so they were
studying content on those subjects and
then trying to we tried to incorporate
sort of activities that
that
encapsulated those
activities and i think it all went
really well
i would say
in the beginning i was kind
and was really afraid of speaking
and then i uh now i try to
you know talk to myself all the time
right because i have to i know i have to
work on my pronunciation so like
when i'm walking alone or waiting for
the bus
i just try to
talk to myself while i'm doing what am i
doing today
say everything so what part of your
english do you think has improved when
you see different aspects of your
language which parts do you feel you
have improved in i checked
the first records of
pronunciation practice and i checked the
latest one too
and there's a difference yes
i certainly notice it yeah yesterday
actually i went
downtown and
the clerk
came to me and
helped me to
buy something right and
he
he has a tattoo in korean here wow when
i saw that i was like whoa you have
tattoo in korea and i said oh can you
read korean so i said yeah i'm korea i'm
from korea and he said oh i thought you
are um
and he he thought i'm some kind of
second generation right okay yeah wow in
here yeah uh
because we didn't talk that much
so
he he said i have
almost no accent right english yeah yeah
so i was like oh thank you in terms of
your english what what do you think has
improved the most in your english
uh in my english uh
my pronunciation the fact that i
i just can't really
distinguish uh
which language i'm like speaking
in and which language we are uh
we have a conversation in
in in in the office like
sometimes i i'm i'm about to start uh to
speak in hungarian because
because i just
feel natural yeah so you feel totally
natural in english in other words you
never feel like what they say or you
basically you understand everything yes
yes my speaking uh
for my speaking there's still room for
improvement right because i'm i'm i'm
still sometimes struggling to find the
correct perfect word but my reading yeah
i can read everything
my
listening too yes
do
you